hello folks and welcome back to
GameSpot's coverage of the electronic
triple 2016 on Daniel are joined by
Michael my hardy and is a standing chin
I love you beautiful man torben my
friend we're here to talk about him I
was bet to say to bias Reaper i'm not
sure if anyone ever calls him that
anymore i think i got thrown out with
the first one who lit that briefly right
yeah everything's badly maybe one game I
don't know agent 47 is had a wonderful
renaissance this year yes in the form of
hitman yes just she's in one hit man
yeah yeah and let's talk about that
first of all because there was sort of
you know I guess a bit of as you know
anytime you release a game in a sort of
a non you know just boxed copy there you
know there's a bit of confusion about it
talk a little bit about I guess the
impetus behind releasing hitman is this
like purchase and an episodic okay game
um so this goes back to absolution right
I was on absolution I was working with
the guys who built contracts mode hmm
which was to create your own target
thing that and we shipped it and very
quickly as you always do with the game
you discover things that are perhaps not
as good as they could have been or
things that you designed as diligently
as you could but it turns out that when
you put tens of millions of players into
it stuff is not working the way right
the three things in absolution that were
kind of troubled were the disguised
system that was maybe a bit too
punishing a little bit difficult to
understand all right it was the scoring
system that got a lot of flak because it
was stupidly punishing and finally the
contracts economy was just busted um and
the problem with the way we built that
game the problem with the way we
understood hard to build games that
point was almost like packing packing a
trunk to go on a trip right you stuff
stuff into it and your stuff stuff into
it your friend to sit on it so you can
close it if you open that thing again
it's going to explode yeah we shipped it
and then we thought okay what can we do
without opening this trunk again and we
managed to get the disguise system kind
of fix but we couldn't touch the other
things because it was just right too
much and the other problem we're packing
for a trip is that once you've hit your
first Waypoint you realize you brought
all the wrong
yeah it's nicely so um so a bunch of us
sat down and we thought what are the
things that we wish we could have done
and we we identify things like the
ability to kind of go into a level and
make game mechanical changes like for
example saying okay suddenly these guys
are going to enforce disguises or you
can't climb the side of the building all
right you have to do the whole thing in
five minutes but not knowing ahead of
time what everything would be but have
like a framework that will allow us to
inject new rules you'll recognize these
from escalation mode yes idea of
complications we wanted to be able to go
back and create and inject new game
design into levels like new targets and
new security setups and entirely new
activities in the levels which is what
we've done with the summer bonus episode
by creating the film set and marrakech
by night yeah so it was like in that
scope of things that we arrived at this
understanding that we wanted to have a
game as a platform right I mean it
sounds like an awful buzz word but this
this idea that we could touch these
things in a way that didn't require us
to patch constantly and that brought us
can to where we are today where we have
episodes that come out and bring a new
location and a bunch of set up and we
have weekly content drops of escalations
or challenges or elusive targets that
can really change the level the one
that's live right now in III actually
goes into that back area of the palace
where usually Deco meets an avocado and
you break as they can check them in the
river yeah like one thing that happens
there we've lifted all of that out and
now there's a party that right and all
the people who could normally get in
can't get in and there's a whole piece
of set up there and our ability to do
that or even our ability to go in and do
things like marrakech by night that you
see there which yeah as much karma
cooler more more welcoming marrakech
that is on this scale of things that we
can do with this game platform that
we've come up with yeah it's always
interested me to the episodic structure
itself I'm always kind of skeptical
about when I hear it at first but uh you
know in retrospect this game just really
works with it because it like the way
people talk about this game is so
different than thank you when you talk
about the earlier hit man's you know you
play through the entire game someone
says oh I saw this is how i did this
this is how I complete this objective or
I use
this guy's but this game it's like every
single episode that releases is just
under this really tight scrutiny so then
people really learn it like the ins and
outs and that's really interesting to me
when I come into work and I hear like
Peter reviews that are saying like yeah
I just played this again and i heard i
just found this like you really learn it
inside it out i'm assuming that was your
intention baby yes but it it was i think
the the big realization for me with
releasing this game now is how it almost
seems we consume games now right when we
release something it's live and it's
streamed and people have passion and
opinions about it and we watch this and
sometimes we're sitting there thinking
should we fix this like moment to moment
yeah it's like no wait and see how it
settles an example of this in the
sapienza level you can unlock this
breaching charge device think you slap
it on a door you trigger it'll blow the
door and blow a safe and that kind of
thing game mechanically it's a low-yield
not was a non-lethal explosive right but
people worked out that it actually had a
very very high physics impetus ok so
then an elusive target comes out the
first one the target is the forger at
one point he walks out onto a balcony so
one of our fans works out that if he
takes a fire extinguisher puts it on in
the garden on top of this breaching joke
is that reaching job hitting me fire
extinguisher smashes the guy in the face
and killers awesome in a game mode with
permit if right yeah and it's like works
what did you think as designers when he
saw the hum that's designed it started
to see she's right but yeah it goes back
to to the infamous traffic accident kill
in a new life in blood money mmm which
was like at the dawn of YouTube where
someone figured out that if they went
into the specific level and triggered a
specific series of events the target
would panic call for his backup run out
into the street is back up with getting
the car drive over hit him and kill him
and it's like we did not script that we
did their eyes on that it was like an
emergent result of hundreds of hours of
like abuse of the systems and that led
to contracts mode in absolution right
and in many ways it's it's informed a
lot of the design decisions that we've
done on the new game which are embracing
the fact that there is
craziness and we're seeing sapienza yeah
running here this is the film set this
is a superhero epic sci-fi movie being
shot in sapienza the target is a film
director mmm it's a lot of fun because
he's an old school guy he does his own
stunts he likes pyrotechnics and
physical effects and that's a dangerous
of interesting ways because notice
everyone said yet to Mike's point I mean
the hitman games were one of those games
that replaying levels was always fun i
wasn't like you were just constantly
trying to get to the next one but there
also was this element of you want to see
what happens next so it was almost as if
the game was sort of pulling your
attention in two different ways it was
like play with the sandbox but also hey
mixed see what the next one is yeah so
you know in a weird way and again it
goes to like gamers don't know what they
want right because I people probably
saying like I want to play a full hitman
game I don't think sixty dollars not to
wait but you've actually allowed this
like the players to breathe and
experience the level and play with that
emerging gameplay and trick things and
you know in a way that like the game is
such a long tail it feels like this game
is coming out every two months or
whatever because is like a new thing did
you expect that that would happen or
were you worried that there would be a
backlash to like why are they asking me
to pay for sixty dollars for one level
and promising me the rest let's be
honest right it was on us to prove that
this was the thing that could make sense
that it was valid not just to wait for
everything to come up but I think you're
on the money right people are people are
realizing that they have time and they
feel kind of liberated to go in and
explore and discover the fact that
everything in our games is built up
around the context of the level the
progression system and a challenge all
of this is about mastering a level but
talking about liberation that was kind
of a an interesting outcome of the
escalation design installations are like
these little multistage missions where
we say kill a guy dressed as a waiter
with a saber okay can you also do that
if you've got to hide the bodies in 90
seconds can you also do that if you have
to delete tapes of this but you hear and
you also do can you also do can you also
do it right kind of a horde mode for
hitman yeah but what came out of that is
that it's liberating because there's no
fiction there's no reason why 47 is
doing this right it's McCann
the mechanics of fun and going through a
level and then suddenly encountering the
fact that hey right you can only carry
this weapon in this disguise why have
fun with this challenge hmm and it's
liberating and helps I think will help
me right when I first played the
prototypes of this to to realize that
hey the basic mechanics of this game are
a lot of fun right we do tend to kind of
get locked into the fiction and the
fantasy of this right or powerful
assassin yeah sometimes it's when we
live stream it me and Travis our
community manager when we live stream in
it always goes south yeah hash Travis
proximity bombs up but it's fun because
it just lets you play with the mechanics
yeah it's argue and say yeah like to use
a dumb metaphor as I comparing it's like
comparing the earlier ones to like
novels where this is a collection of
short stories and you can get attached
to them individually but then also like
the overarching structure of the entire
game is still interesting like there's
that through line that kind of connects
them all yeah I don't know that's always
that's been interesting to medicines to
start releasing it's also been I think
key to the way we're trying to imagine
our our story and our development of the
narrative in the game because absolution
was an interesting study of the
character in kind of like a particular
kind of story very grindhouse gritty how
many lives will you take to save one
kind of high-concept thing maybe not sue
her approachable from the point of view
of blood money but with making this one
we I think we made the decision really
early on that we didn't we didn't want
to do a hero's journey with a guy right
right we wanted to keep 47 the stoic
cold guy in the middle and tell stories
around him rice which is wonderful I I
always find it funny that there are two
hitman movies because hitman to me has
always been it's like a cipher for like
the player to just it's like a game of
chess right it's like all of these
mechanics so to me the full was never
unlike again if there are some wonderful
moments throughout the franchise like
I'm just thinking about the coffin scene
with the credits running ahead and all
data I like Pitt mom wanted some like
wonderful moments in as well with like
his origin story and all that stuff but
yeah it's like I guess you guys pick
your poison you meant okay you know what
people notice the video game like the x
KS Kadesh mode is a perfect example I'm
not we know it's a game like we know
it's
you know that there's there are some
games we shouldn't see the puppet
strings but it's perfectly fine in
hitman to know what where does proper
swings are an end to sort of mess with
them it precisely that I mean it's like
this giant clockwork machine and when
you've mastered it you know if you stick
the thing in here this machine will tear
itself apart and your two targets will
die and no one will be blamed and you
can do it in less than a minute all
right and that's as designed Robin I
could talk to you all day about this I'm
sure micra to we have to cut this one
but before you go when is the next so is
this technically episode for all that we
call this the summer so this is the
summer bonus episode episode 4 comes
after this is the midpoint for its outer
July 19th on your preferred console or
digital platform awesome wonderful thank
you so much for coming on really focus
best of luck with the rest of hitman
season 1 thank you yeah and best of luck
words if there is a season 2 i'm sure
there was people seem to be chewing this
one dancer thank you so much going on
really pretty eyes thank you for
watching everyone and make sure you get
those questions in sorry I was hogging
torben there for that segment we've got
Jason on in a second to talk about Star
Park the fractured butthole and a bunch
of people looking forward to this one so
stick around back in a couple of minutes